es un soleado día de octubre y los
nadadores de la piscina pública de noyón
A las afueras de París acuden a este
centro como si fuera una mañana de mitad
de verano
es encantador extraordinario el clima
está hermoso
los trajes de baño nos mantienen cálidas
y es genial poder llevarlos en el
exterior
el agua estaba apenas a 19 grados
Celsius muy por debajo de los habituales
26 para estas fechas del año ya que el
personal tuvo que apagar la calefacción
de su piscina olímpica
en septiembre de 2020 el precio del gas
era un promedio de 11 euros megavatio
Hora
ahora es de 151 euros un año después
dejaré que usted haga los cálculos pero
para nosotros representa un ahorro de
entre 45 a 50.000 euros para cada uno de
los meses más fríos
y aunque puede que suene como una medida
radical para algunos los clientes están
aceptando muy bien las temperaturas más
frías
[Música]
es pura felicidad nunca antes había
llevado un traje de baño pensé que
quizás impactarían nuestros movimientos
pero para nada es bastante lo contrario
Es agradable y bonito nos sentimos mucho
mejor después de entrenar con el traje
en Agua Fría a cuando está caliente
el gobierno francés anunció planes para
reducir el consumo de energía en un 10%
para los próximos dos años ante unas
facturas que no dejan de subir algunas
piscinas han sido incapaces de
sostenerse y han sido forzadas a cerrar